EU economics and finance ministers have
made progress towards completing an anti
abuse clause to stop multinational
companies avoiding tax payments the EU
so called parent-subsidiary directive
was adopted in 2011 to ensure that
profits made by cross-border groups are
not taxed twice and anti-abuse clause is
needed to prevent companies from
exploiting any tax loopholes The
ministers are expected to finalize the
claws at their next council in early
December we are now very well placed to
reach such a definite agreement at the
echofon meeting in December especially
in the current context that we all know
there is no time to waste in reducing
any opportunities for abusive practices
and aggressive tax planning the
ministers also made progress on a
financial transactions tax that eleven
EU member states want to introduce to
ensure that the financial sector makes a
fair contribution to tax revenues they
expressed hope that it could be
finalised by the end of this year and
into force in 2016 in tandem with the
European Commission The ministers
debated a compromise on the revised
gross national income and v8t figures
which would require some countries
notably the United Kingdom Italy and the
Netherlands to pay substantial sums of
money into the EU budget by the first of
December the Commission's been asked to
come up with a proposal to allow
countries to make such payments in
stages when the amount is exceptionally
high as it is this time around in other
business the council committed to
mobilize more finances to help fight
climate change ahead of next month's UN
climate talks in Lima Peru